it just slipped my attention that
i i missed my booktube anniversary i
never really thought it'd be a year of
consistent videos i definitely wouldn't
have stuck with it if it weren't for the
kind of positivity and
kindness and support that i get on a
daily basis from from everyone the main
reason i want to make this type of video
is because i feel like there are things
i can impart wisdom that i can impart on
those who
are thinking of starting a channel or
are or have started a channel so i wrote
down some notes some little things that
just occurred to me like to me the first
thing that really struck me when i
posted that first booktube video was oh
people either just don't care or they're
polite
because they're on the same boat they're
on the same page and they found my video
because they're a small channel too or
something like that and that's the
majority of your interactions i think
when you're starting a channel and then
you start to get people who aren't just
part of that community they're just
casual watchers or whatever when you
first
start make anything on youtube it's not
going to be seen by anybody unless you
find a way to shove it in front of
people's faces
literally how just how it is unless
you're like
targeting i just smudged my glasses i'm
just gonna get into some of my points
the first hundred subscribers are the
hardest
to get that it felt like it took forever
to get 100 subscribers so it took me
about six months to get my first
thousand subscribers
and it took me another six months to get
15 000 more subscribers what i'm saying
is that things kind of snowball the more
subscribers you have the more
subscribers you're going to get it's
kind of like
capitalism
making consistent videos is really
important
just because the algorithm favors that
also i mean this is just stuff that any
youtuber would tell you like make
consistent videos but don't do it at a
low quality post it when you're
comfortable and and maybe it's not for
everybody because i have a i have a
tendency where i'm majority of the
videos i post
i would not post them unless i had this
mental like pressure i had this absolute
schedule i have not broken that's like i
have to make a video i'll tell you
probably
10 of the videos i've made i've really
believed in getting feedback on videos
can be surreal because it's like i
filmed this
last minute out of because i was running
out of time i edited it finished editing
it pulled an all-nighter majority of the
videos i've made i've pulled an
all-nighter filmed and edited them at
like 3 a.m incredibly sleep deprived i'm
really tooting my own horn here when i
do this whole one-year celebration
because for me
that's a big
that's a big thing to have this kind of
consistent thing you know it's not
always
fun um i don't know like any other way
to put it but
every time i make a video every time
after i make a video i'm always
extremely pleased it's super super
rewarding
so this is not supposed to supposed to
turn into a therapy session so i will
move on don't stress about reading if
you're going to stay sane while doing
you can't stress about reading because
reading is a passion of mine i love
reading find a way to make videos that
don't rely always on you
reading something i feel like i found a
comfort zone where i know if i'm haven't
finished a book i can still make
something i can still rehash
brandon sanderson interviews i think
that's something to help stay sane if
you're embarking on a booktube channel
i'm recording this video at 2 a.m every
time i make a video i i do this late
it's 2 a.m so i'll probably be done in
like 15 minutes and i won't probably
start editing until like 3 30 and by
that time it's kind of crunch time put
your heart into whatever you make
because you'll have to make a lot of it
you'll have to live with it literally
anything you put out there is a gamble
you don't know what's going to pop off
you don't know what's going to do well
i've had videos that i made you know
eight nine months ago
that when i first made them they had
like 300 views and they stayed that way
for months and months and then suddenly
it's like 20 000 views and then there's
other videos where i'm like oh this is
going to get a lot of views this will do
well
no
you roll with it
but what i'm trying to say is that you
don't know when a video is going to
do do well so you just have to put your
best into it growth is not
um
a steady thing you know it comes in
waves you're gambling every time you put
a video out there you have no idea
what's going to go good no it's
go good you have no idea what's going to
do well just because a video doesn't do
well early on doesn't mean it's not
going to do well later on make what
makes you happy i think the best thing
for someone new on youtube is to find a
niche find a way to
add something to the fun what could you
say that's new or what can you
contribute that there seems to be a lack
of and early on when you have
such a small small views you know you
have like 50 people watching a video
you're way more nervous about how you're
being perceived how you look and act and
the topics you talk about my early
videos were very structured just me
talking to the camera i got sick of that
you know i learned that i don't love
talking to a camera that's why i don't
make videos like this a lot now that i
get more views however it's weird i'm
way less concerned with what people say
or think you gotta try new things follow
what feels right for you and what is fun
for you don't be afraid to borrow
from others because that's everybody on
youtube is borrowing from each other
don't steal somebody's ideas but i mean
it's okay to
get inspiration and
do that sort of thing you know i still
feel like i'm in a kind of experimental
phase i'm looking forward to what the
channel is going to become in the next
year i mean for me it's just about
what's tolerable what can i tolerate
doing
that involves me talking to wrap this up
and i don't sincere post very often so
this is kind of a sincere post i guess
it is a pursuit
i don't even know what i'm saying at
this point my favorite thing
after posting is just seeing all the
dumb jokes that people put in the
comments it's so fun like in on the
discord and on the patreon and all the
everyone's just it's weird it's crazy
it's amazing i still feels like i'm an
imposter or it's just gonna people are
gonna realize that i'm a fraud or i
don't know what i'm i guess i'm
defrauding you of bad memes here's to a
year on booktube thank you i hope you
all have lovely a lovely week
you